if you've actually done any kind of
programming you wouldn't know that
programming is frustrating it's
confusing and sometimes it's even
demoralizing you remember when you just
started you were so motivated so
passionate about the things you can do
with it all you see are people building
their empires with it and affecting
billions of lives with their lines of
code but no one ever told you about
their failures the untold stories of
people who have fallen and the hardships
that brought to them the reality is when
we start programming and building things
break things get stuck projects get
scraped or even worse businesses die and
jobs are lost startups fail and time is
wasted failure after failure are
happening every day but all you see are
the successes that coding brought to
these different people but no one talks
about the path to get there programming
is hard and you will fail at one point
you will doubt yourself you'll say
you're not smart enough that you're not
lucky enough or that you're not gifted
enough worse other people will tell you
that you're not meant for computer
science you're not meant to be an
entrepreneur you're not smart enough to
be a programmer you know what I'll tell
you that I think that some of you are
not born to be programmers you might be
just wasting your time you want to
ignore my advice and close this video
good ignore my advice if that's you then
it means you're bit stubborn but you
don't give up and you care
it means you fail all the time but you
pick yourself back up and you become
stronger it means you're dumb enough to
try to do something impossible but then
you make it loose you push technology to
its limit and you're at the forefront of
innovation and you push even further and
when people tell you that you can't do
it you go ahead and you do it when
people tell you you're wasting your time
you go back and you work twice as hard
and you come back and prove them wrong
when people tell you you're crazy it's a
compliment to you if that sounds like
you then you are a true innovator and we
need more people like you because we
need more people to face the impossible
and conquer it I don't care if you're
just trying to pass a CS course or that
you're building a rocket ship startup
what matter is that you are not stopping
until you reach your goal as a society
we have many many problems but we tackle
them heads on and we keep innovating to
make our lives better on planet earth
one of the problems I care a lot about
is natural disasters I'm partnered with
IBM today to talk about a global
initiative called call for code which
calls for developers to build something
impactful and have a positive change
across the world through their code as
you know there are hundreds of natural
disasters every year like hurricanes
earthquakes floods volcanoes and
wildfires those affect numerous lives
and causes tremendous damage to families
across the globe if you strive for real
impact we desperately need you this is
why the 2019 call for code global
challenge is a competition to ask people
like you to build solutions that help
the health and well-being of these
victims of natural disasters there are
so many aspects of that
we're talking about accessing medical
records providing food and water safely
controlling infectious diseases building
supply distribution networks and even
getting access to mental health during
natural disasters we need all kinds of
technologies here are a few examples of
potential projects you like working on
blockchains
build secure supply networks to
distribute aid to the people in need you
like AI and NLP built BOTS to help
real-time communication you're into data
science analyze and predict what the
affected populations need before they
even ask for it every one of your
project will matter and it will be for
an extremely good cause now of course
this is still a competition so they have
a grand prize of $200,000 not only that
the project with the greatest potential
impact will be implemented through the
IBM code and response initiative and
receive open source support through the
Linux Foundation last year's winning
team project owl has already begun to
deploy their solution in Puerto Rico as
part of the code in response so are you
up for the challenge do the impossible
be an innovator join the coffer code